he's a prime minister determined to
deliver to fix the Northern Ireland
problem
[Applause]
the framework
presents a good deal for the people and
Families of Northern Ireland the Rishi
sunax brexit deal was today unpicked in
the comments we have not yet fully
addressed this fundamental problem which
is the continued application of EU law
for the manufacturing of all Goods in
Northern Ireland rejected by some on his
own side too I think there are things in
the Windsor framework that are damaging
to the United Kingdom damaging to the
union and would actually make the
situation worse than the protocol the
recommendation to the ERG was that we
should vote against the S.I so that I
think is what quite a few of our members
are going to do in a few hours time the
most powerful blow though May well have
been this
order order order we will now suspend
the city the former prime minister
leaving his committee questions to vote
against Rishi sunax brexit deal division
clear the lobby but in the end it was a
rebellion contained eyes to the right
515 the noza left 29. the eyes of it the
eyes have it a lock
the numbers today really mattered 22
conservative MPS voted against the deal
there were also abstentions but
crucially the government did not have to
rely on labor votes and they see that as
a victory Boris voted for Theresa May's
Checkers deal
and put forward the protocol and he
couldn't Vote for This Improvement I
mean I honestly perplexed and surprised
that they didn't feel that they could
vote for it but what we've done here
that I'm really proud of is we've reset
the relationship with the European Union
and with Ireland and that is going to
give us a new basis to have a better
partnership outside the EU there were
high-profile Rebels but this was a test
of Rishi sunak's Authority and he may
just have drawn a line under brexit Ali
Forge Sky News Westminster